what are your views on the current state  of men and women right now when it comes  to relationship feminism being  progressive deterioration of the family  unit well it's definitely happening  there's also an increase in mental  illness overall so i don't know how much  of it has to do with that or maybe a  majority of it is caused by the birth  control pill the birth control pill is  really hard on women it makes completely  sane women go crazy and people don't  talk about it it's like oh side effect  and then we have people who are really  far left being like every male is prone  to violence and like don't associate  with them and they're just like bad  people can't change i think that there  are people who are on the other side men  in particular who are like oh all women  are  ex i think both sides contribute to the  issue and are widening this gap so that  men and women can't communicate